fire arrows as a rule get
way overused in cinema these are a
little more interesting though
hi i'm toby capwell i'm curator of arms
and armor at the wallace collection
in central london since i was a kid i've
been riding horses and fighting and
armor
i've taken part in competitions armored
combat
all over the world today we're going to
be looking at the treatment of medieval
arms and armor
in cinema
what business there's an elf a man and a
dwarf having the rhythm mark
speak quickly yeah this is a great
entrance of a character
you know tolkien imagined the rohirum as
anglo-saxons who fought like knights on
horseback
because the anglo-saxon didn't they rode
horses but they got off
to fight they didn't fight on their
horses the design of the helmet is
derived from early medieval
examples he really should have his chin
strap done up
the helmet is riding a bit too high on
his head
the brow of the helmet the the vertica
the horizontal edge there
should be right down on his eyebrows to
really protect the front of the skull
you want to bring that down as far as it
can go and it can go right down onto
your eyebrows
so i'll stick this on all right this is
one of my own
it's made for me
okay now you see that brow is right down
on my eyes and it's sticking out
beyond my skull right so a weapon comes
in
it can't get to me the skull it might
get there
but that's still safe give me your name
host master
you know things are often more highly
decorated even for practical fighting
than
modern people often imagine they're
going for armor that looks kind of
architectural
like the dwarves build you know caves
and they
work with you know rock and that's under
mountains and stuff so they're
they're looking for a kind of blocky
aesthetic it's starting to look a bit
too much like
like polyurethane here to me something
about
metal that it has a weight it has a
rigidity
that rubber and plastic and polyurethane
don't have i got to dock them a couple
of points here for the fit and the chin
strap
but it's still got to be like an 8 out
of 10.
[Music]
what's he doing i think his son was
already a knight at this point i don't
know why he feels the need to knight him
again
this is a this is a total mishmash of
pretty good
and pretty not so good the mail that
you're seeing in close up here
is real mail and you can actually even
see the rivets
that are closing each of the links it's
not fitting him well and it's not
tailored to him
it's something that's been just hoiked
out of a van and stuck
on the actor a lot of uh film
mail is just like plastic links
butted together sprayed silver for a lot
of uses it's fine
but they don't have the rivets real mail
is you know iron links riveted closed
i appreciate the fact that he's got a
lining under there he's got padded
textile
under the mail which you have to have
otherwise it is going to do precisely
nothing for you
a lot of exposed throats there and
they've stuck
random articulated shoulder plates over
the male shirt
this is robert the bruce in the early
14th century
they were starting to introduce more
hard
armor they're a long way from full plate
armor at this period
they're a significant way away really
from articulated constructions like that
that look a bit like the
tail of a lobster or whatever it's a
later thing
and the shoulders were less of a
priority in this period
if you're going to put plates on a guy
in this period it should be on the
elbows and the knees
and here you can see his mail is a
little off center
his bagging around his throat just is
bad
the key thing about a male hood is that
it has a piece called event tail
which comes up and ties up to the chin
and it's sculpted to protect the whole
throat
you know this is this is armor that's
doing nothing because i can stab him
straight through his windpipe
this film is is actively engaging with
real heraldry
heraldry is the system of colors and
shapes
put on to shields as a form of visual
identification
it's when all these guys are in armor
it's hard to tell who's who
heraldry was the answer and it works
very well they got things wrong that
they didn't have to get wrong but they
still did a fair amount that's right
seven out of ten
what nothing i like this little scene
because it shows that getting shot with
arrows
isn't immediately fatal and gilda ray
here
jones companion who was incidentally a
serial killer
in real life he was a quite pretty
despicable
child murderer and anyway he
knows that he can take a hit she's not
wearing armor in this scene
he is shot for shot a longbow arrow has
very little chance of hurting a man
inside you need the kind of mass volume
that henry v
organized in his armies to put so many
arrows downrange
that somebody's gonna get hurt no matter
what i
asked for grandiose coronation and this
is what you get this
he wouldn't do that almost certainly
he'd wear his coronation robes
and all of his knights certainly
wouldn't wear armor to a coronation
certainly not rusty banged up stuff like
that
most of this is aluminum this armor is
made by terry english
who's one of the most famous modern
armorers working in cinema
he's made armor for lots of things he
made arnold schwarzenegger's
mr freeze armor for the batman movie
he's made space marines armor for the
aliens
and he's done a fair amount of
historical stuff the king here is
putting on
gold armor it's gold colored and this is
actually
this is actually good this doesn't look
like gold armor
but fully gilded armor where you have
steel armor
and then it's copper plated and then
it's
fire gilded where you mix gold with
mercury
and you apply this mercury gold mixture
if you then heat that mercury up and you
boil it off
it leaves the gold chemically bonded to
the steel
normally most people wouldn't be able to
afford that i mean really only kings can
afford this
and not all kings but the french kings
liked this
it was it was a distinctive uh thing
actually it creates an image of a king
as like
the sun manifested in human form like a
superhuman being but it would have been
nicer if they'd given terry the budget
to guild it properly
i'll give it a 4 out of 10. we've
already been through this before
we both know you haven't got it a sword
is not a gun
pointing a sword at someone out of range
with your arms fully extended so you
have nowhere to go with it
doesn't achieve anything except making
you look like you've never held a sword
in your life you point your weapon out
there like that he's going to take it
away from you
[Music]
there's often not enough color in
medieval depictions in cinema
medieval people loved color bright color
and richness it didn't populate their
world
very much otherwise
okay so you've got your leader your king
leading a cavalry
charge he they're in wedge formation
with the king
at the point of the wedge which is great
this is how it's done
the guy on the point of the wedge is
steering the whole cavalry charge he's
like the guidance system
on a missile the wedge formation is one
of the most
effective formations for a heavy cavalry
charge
he's got his chin strap done up love
that he's still got his visor up
which is good because at this stage he's
still far
enough away from the enemy where he's
got other things to worry about
a cavalry charge might start when you're
maybe
600 meters away from the enemy line
but you're not going to be full pelt
straight off you need to
start the charge in good order he's got
to look around
and make sure his formation is
maintaining its position
they're keeping their cohesion if he
starts running too fast then they
then they have to catch up and then they
start getting too spread out they've got
to stay close
he's got to be watching that fine but
now the real test of this sequence
and the thing that hollywood hates to do
is cover its famous actors faces but in
a real cavalry charge this guy once he's
got himself set up
he needs to close that visor and let's
see if they do it
he could close it right about now now
would be good
hey he's closed it i'll give it a seven
if i could change one thing i would
change this he's wearing his gorget
on the outside of his breastplate the
gorget is that neck plate
he should actually have plates covering
his throat the gorget has neck plates in
here and it comes down and has this
larger chest plate
that chest plate should be underneath
the breastplate
the breastplate has a turned edge to
stop things sliding up into your
face but if anything does get passed it
hits the gorget
but in game of thrones they habitually
put them on the outside
and it's a it's a howler that i just i
can't abide
[Music]
and fire arrows were a thing especially
in naval warfare when you've got
key pieces of equipment you want to set
on fire like sails and rigging and
things
fire arrows as a rule get get way over
used
in cinema these are a little more
interesting though there's something
more interesting going on you see it's
not just a lump of burning material
stuck on an arrow
they've actually got some kind of
explosive charge
on these arrows that has a fuse
and this is actually much more
historically plausible
there are early incendiary manuals from
the 15th and 16th centuries
that give designs for different kinds of
gunpowder bombs
and other explosive devices to be put on
arrows and crossbow bolts
i love this right here that's armor
doing its job
you know an arrow when it hits you in
full armor
it'll probably glance off that's what
armor is designed to do but if it hits
you square
and it gets enough purchase again it can
start to bite into the steel
and if it hits you somewhere on the arm
or the shoulder
where the steel is thinner it might even
get through
chances are most arrows are not going to
get through enough to do meaningful
damage to the person inside
but they are going to get stuck and
seeing a knight fighting
on the walls in a siege with arrows
stuck in him
is the best thing i've seen all day 10
out of 10
absolutely just for that
one of the absolute best treatments of
historical armor
in any film ever is in lawrence
olivier's 1944
film henry v but the film is set
and the design is led by the
the reality of um of clothing and
equipment and architecture and so forth
of the early 15th century
one of his historical advisors was my
predecessor at the wallace collection
the keeper of arms and armor
in the mid-20th century sir james mann
and olivier went to the wallace
collection
and he saw the collection and he worked
with james mann another
arms and armor scholar named charles
beard and that film
looks just like a 15th century
manuscript come to life and it's real
steel
armor on all of these actors
and it's one of the best ever